alors que les taux d'intérêt et
l'inflation laissent nombre de projets
immobiliers à l'étape d'envie certains
se lancent dans l'auto-construction de
leur maison et font preuve d'une
ingéniosité sans borne pour limiter les
coûts rencontrent avec Philippe sur le
chantier de sa maison à
Saint-Martin-le-Beau ce bricoleur
expérimenté a choisi de construire sa
maison avec des conteneurs maritimes qui
l'aménage patiemment objectif pour lui
moins de 150 000 euros terrain compris
Aurélie Renaud Philippe a déjà rénové
plusieurs maisons cet ancien électricien
devenu fonctionnaire construit
aujourd'hui son propre logement son
budget est serré alors il se tourne vers
la construction en containers il en
achète quatre sur internet pour un
montant total de 15000 euros pour le
reste il mise sur des bons plans les
fenêtres c'est des fins de série Les la
porte c'est une fin de série
la baie vitrée c'est une baie vitrée qui
a été démontée suite à un changement de
projet
depuis huit mois Philippe passe ce
week-end dès ses vacances à transformer
ses containers maritimes qui ont fait le
tour du monde en une maison de 90 mètres
carrés l'arrivée des quatre grandes
boîtes métalliques avaient suscité
beaucoup de curiosités
qui étaient en face là qui sont partis
de matin travailler qui sont arrivés à
midi
et pas d'utile d'être fou pour faire un
truc pour comme ça mais ça aide
pose des fenêtres isolation charpente
placo Philippe ne compte pas ses heures
de travail son objectif est simple se
loger confortablement près de Tours et
de son travail sans se mettre en
difficulté financière dans le voisinage
les maisons coûtent environ 240000 euros
ma première estimation était à aux
alentours de 120.000 euros terrain
inclus et suite à une nette progression
des prix
suite à aux crises diverses et variées
il faut compter 140 000 Philippe compte
emménager dans son logement container
fin septembre au final il aura mis neuf
mois pour construire de ses propres
mains sa maison